bonjour jean marc belotti merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france ce matin alors
le rapport sénatorial chiffre à 6,5
milliards d'euros la perte de recettes
pour l'état résultant du processus de
cession de certaines autoroutes
est ce que c'est un cadeau fait aux
sociétés autoroutières comme certains le
déplorent
bah oui c'est toujours un cadeau ce qui
est bien dommage c'est que ce sont les
routes les plus sûrs en plus et
curieusement ça ces sorties de 15 août
alors évidemment ça c'est déjà généré
par là l'homme la loi d'orientation des
mobilités et puis ce décret arrive le 15
août une fois tout le monde a le dos
tourné
c'est bien dommage puisque comme on le
dit et comme les sénateurs le disent
c'est un taux de rentabilité qui est
très intéressant dont pourraient
bénéficier l'état et il n'est pas
habituel un pas normal que ce soient des
sociétés privées qui récupère toute
cette manne d'autant plus que comme on
dirait l'argent généré par les ag de
l'automobile ou enfin le sujet de la
route en règle générale est quand même
aussi assez conséquent et pourrait
revenir à la l'entretien de ces mots et
2c de ces voies routières en fait et ce
fameux décret 1 publié à mi août relatif
à la loi d'orientation des mobilités de
décembre 2019 ouvre la voie à une
privatisation des routes nationales
est ce que c'est une erreur ou et c'est
encore un nouveau cadeau fait aux
sociétés otor autoroutière je dirais
l'e2c c'est une erreur c'est une prog
est une erreur parce que c'est une
prolongation du cadeau alors
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de se
poser la question si on doit continuer à
laisser la concession des sociétés
privées on nous parle de privatiser
d'aidés nationales
alors c est une porte ouverte puisque
bien évidemment si on commence à
privatiser des nationales on va encore
générer des bénéfices pour ces sociétés
privées qui se levait défi cela c'est un
bénéfice qui luttera pas l'état mais en
tout cas pour les routes nationales et
pour l'élu réseau secondaire il doit
absolument pas être privatisée
venus est encore encore moins être
payant que ce soit payée à l'état ou à
des concessions privées
ça doit rester d'état doit rester des
voix pardon libre et est gratuite
quelle est la solution est ce qu'il faut
réduire à la durée
de ces concessions autoroutières ou
carrément mettre un terme à ces contrats
en fait c'est un débat qui existe depuis
longtemps et là le sénat vient de rendre
son rapport
donc je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
ce rapport est justement il faut
vraiment se poser la question d'annuler
d'annuler la concession à ces sociétés
privées c'est eux c'est comment dire à
un post qui rapporte de l'argent et ça
me semblerait tout à fait normal que ce
soit l'état et les français qui en
bénéficient et selon vous dernière
question rapidement à ce que l'état
aurait-il ait les ressources financières
pour jeu pour gérer seul la gestion de
nos routes et ainsi est généré à deir
certes des recettes à plus long terme
encore une fois lorsqu'on voit la manne
que génèrent les usagers de la route
on peut considérer pourrait considérer
effet alors je pas spécialiste bien
évidemment mais on pourrait considérer
que alors entre la manne générée par les
usagers de la route les impôts que nous
payons
on peut quand même considérer que l'état
pourrait prendre en charge les
autoroutes
et puisque de toute nation et des
bénéfices je pense que les gens du
public ne sont pas plus idiot que les
gens du privé et ça pourrait
effectivement constituer des rapports
intéressante pour l'état et donc pour
les jolies la route et pour les français
en règle générale merci beaucoup jean
marc belotti d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de la fédération française des
motards en colère de pas